in the wake of their humiliating defeat
in 2016
and after trump had called them all out
for their disastrous policies
democrats and their celebrity boosters
were seething
just 24 hours after the inauguration
this was their message yes
i have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the white house
we are here to be nasty
i'm nasty over the next months and years
we will be called upon to
intensify our demands for social justice
to become more militant in our defense
of vulnerable populations
militant well i'll say fast forward to
today
when we're seeing a disturbing uptick in
politically
motivated violence mostly from the left
abusive behavior
vile language and in some cases physical
attacks are visited upon people
for no other reason except for the fact
that they're conservative supporters of
the president
just this week here in washington a
trump supporter announced a
meet-up of fellow activists at a trump
hotel
then someone using an anonymous twitter
account with the handle
dream star justice responded with the
image
of a handgun and the message i'm coming
with a gun and i expect to get
numerous blood stains make america great
again hats as trophies
though the account which supported the
far left democratic socialist has since
been deleted
d.c police and the fbi investigated the
mass murder threat
authorities are right to take these
threats seriously
and over the weekend a republican
congressional candidate in california
rudy peters
who will join us in just a moment was in
a booth at a fall festival
when a man named farzad fazeli
approached him
an angry fazeli yelled profanities about
president trump
and then rushed the republican candidate
fazeli
pulled out a switchblade which he meant
to use on peter's
well the knife thankfully malfunctioned
and the candidate fought back
fazeley's been charged with a felony
count of making deadly threats
and other misdemeanors now this all
comes on the heels of a spate of
vicious attacks over the summer where
trump officials and republicans
were targeted in public places
sarah huckabee sanders pam bondi
homeland security chief kirsten nielsen
and stephen miller were all set upon by
[Applause]
and activists tens of thousands of
people who come here seeking asylum in
the united states
what would mr rogers think about you and
your legacy in florida taking away
health insurance with people with
preaching
resistant conditions sam bondi shame on
you
shame on you
even moderate republicans like susan
collins
are subject to abuse colin's office on
capitol
hill has been slammed by calls to vote
against supreme court nominee brett
kavanaugh
if you care about women's choice
if you vote for him you are standing
there reckless reckless
cyclist woman standing there letting
letting trump
and his appointees steal health care
from millions of americans
feel the right to choose what women do
with their bodies and you stood by that
oh i didn't know i'm so naive
like the destructive antics of antifa or
the rioting that swamp baltimore
you can always count on the left to
justify aggression
this is msnbc contributor yamiche
alcindor when you listen to those
and having been out on the campaign
trail it's the passion of people it's
obviously abusive
and the language that they're being
that's being used is abhorrent
but you also feel that they're talking
about life and death issues
now it's important to focus on the word
but that you use it's abhorrent but
life and death issues in other words as
if to say
the abuse coming from the left is almost
justified
reading between the lines as they like
to say well that's certainly what james
hodgkinson thought
when he tried to assassinate republican
steve scalise at a baseball field
in virginia last year the threats the
demonization
the violence it's all of a peace and by
the way steve scalise will join us in
just a moment
activists on the left has cr have
created basically a deadly
ideology where harassment and even doing
bodily harm
has become essentially a legitimate tool
of the resistance
this is congresswoman maxine waters from
this weekend
there are those who said uh that we lack
civility
when i got up and talked about the
president's cabinet
just tell them you're not welcome here
anywhere
it frightened a lot of people and of
course the line president
said that i had threatened all of his
constituents
i did not threaten his constituents his
supporters
i do that all the time but i didn't do
it that time
[Applause]
that's just utterly disgraceful and it's
not funny
you know why it's not funny because
lives are now being endangered by
reckless speech like this it's not
political debate we're not debating the
issues here it's a
conversation that goes one way you're
abhorrent
you're awful you're like hitler you're a
nazi
so we will destroy you by any means
necessary
that's how the game goes well i say it's
time for the democratic party
to not only condemn this hate speech but
to repudiate these repeated political
acts of terror
before someone loses their life
political battles on both sides
you bet republicans and democrats should
be limited
to discourse and debate and sure protest
that's fine
to allow this dangerous trend though to
continue
of the kind of stuff we've been seeing
is going to take our republic
and our politics to places we dare not
go
and that's the angle